okay let's go cube fanatics 10 seconds
until kickoff 1-minute warzone rated 96
players
hi 1700 rating time handicap let's do it
give me the ticker show me the ticker
runic squatty um u HQ e for gambit no
why am I playing this line why am i
doing it this is not gonna lead to any
quick kills actually this is already bad
news for me let's take that and I'm
getting pieces here are upon ending a
Pawnee thing upon watch out clean bad
stuff can happen quick is it gonna
happen is it gonna happen here it's
gonna open up I want to open up we're
gonna have a queen exchange Hartley oh
just give a check right here you silly
you silly silly silly check and I can
take here with a check
you silly did I just really say that you
silly you silly okay focus now focus now
they reside back to time at six six and
couple are a few twos let's go see five
is where it's at let's go Sicilian uh
okay let's get this in oh I want to do
that stupid mouse I could still blame my
mouse can I I could still play of them
no mouse acceleration anymore I'm
playing without the acceleration right
here force watch out for checks maybe
one day pawn push of Bishop here or just
a free piece three pieces
three pieces I should have played Knight
here would have been more devastating
let's defend that this has to be a pain
doesn't it it's open stuff up my knight
wants to get in here he's gonna have a
lot of fun isn't he
take care it's castle my bishop out
should probably take this Knight
why haven't I been taking this Knight
I'll take him down and then a fork
deadly forks watch out for the deadly
forks where are the tricky Forks here
I'm dropping that night but they dropped
the Queen if they take they kind of have
to take don't they
23 checks checks where are the mates
somebody tell me it's just straight
Queens it's easier it's easier I have
enough I have enough fuel enough gas
here okay that Knights dead I'm okay
with the time though why did I do that
ah bad technique look at my king do I
really have to work my king into a giant
ball right here yeah I really just had
to do that didn't I I really had to do
that time time winner 6:12 is up there
let's go efore all right actually
they're moving a little bit quicker not
as many
all right let's crunch that Bishop it
goes here it's dead it's still go here I
want to get to that square this opens up
now this part can be taken but this is
brutal isn't it should probably defend
that now there's a problem now there's a
giant problem isn't there a giant
problem I go so far as to say a giant
problem right now
tricky discoveries more discoveries
around the corner
oh I shoot just taking the night why not
just take the night I'm looking for mate
though I want me is it gonna be mate
where does that mean there had to have
been mate
okay this is this has to be made soon
right right here the bishop has to block
and that's gonna be game over there we
go back to tournament 12 I'm up there
twelve three twelves and an eleven Ches
for fun 1125 minutes and change okay
they've given me the d4 square they're
gonna play that though they are well I
shouldn't have done that
I wanna keep my Queen on this diagonal
because you know what I'm setting up by
now you know what I'm setting up if
you've been here before
tricky tricky tricky H - H - you've seen
it again H - that might become a t-shirt
it might that's it there's there will be
nothing else on that it'll be a plain
t-shirt it'll just say H - okay here we
go and everybody is just gonna have to
understand what that really means
okay one minute and change this guy is
easy what's going on here um
okay we got to do some home prep here
let's move that home cooking time who's
up there
I got an on mover that should actually
be a forfeit yes they got a forfeit
that's right I forgot about that
back determine I got the W for that one
there's a fifteen second rule that was a
quick kill a quick winner a quick winner
that one was give me the quick winners
let's go night let's go Bishop my
LightSquared bishop wants to play and I
have not had enough this does not always
work by the way sometimes it definitely
backfires
yeah sometimes it definitely backfires
that up hime is dead it's okay though
isn't it it's just an open G file maybe
they'll take it leave it out for bait
need more than just a night out there
for bait here we go let's open stuff up
right now
pawn push is probably good just back up
wow what a bug what a bug get that night
out of there what it oh I'm dropping my
pond okay let's do this
watch out for the tricky Knights watch
out for him okay there might be a pawn
push eventually oh boy that's gonna be
disaster isn't it okay let's trade
Queens oh man my kick is in a giant box
here it's in a giant box why did I do
that
my bishops gonna get kicked around oh
yeah just run home just run home you
wanted to go there did you uh what a
disaster no not really
eleven seconds Premal time period of
time why did I do that why did I do that
I look at my bishop it's stupid
it's a stupid bishop oh I'm getting
mated I'm getting made why didn't I see
that me uh where I can't even check the
standings like I made in oh you see I
was just telling you about the fishing
pole it does not always work you do not
always come home with the fish
no sometimes you're the fish and your
man you just I don't even know what I'm
saying anymore I don't know what I'm
saying ever haha I hope you talking
about oh I just played chess quit it
with your fishing pole man everybody is
sick and tired of it man you just think
you could go fishing whenever you want
sometimes it's not appropriate to go
fishing
ah was devastating that was absolutely
devastating do you realize that usually
I have a bet armor time burning on my
back pocket
none of that my opponent said no I will
end the game right now me ah ah that's
what you get that's what you get you
think you're just a fisherman on a
chessboard here oh that's not gonna
happen again though it's not gonna
happen again where is it let me push
this pawn to victory lane victory lane
where are you at I got to defend this
square what am i doing I'm on tilt right
now just play around tilt beware
let's exchange Queens actually it's not
really working
haha that's not really working too great
is it yeah I'm getting kicked around I
have east six fortunately oh man this is
gonna kill me
this is this nights gonna kill me he's a
killer isn't he look at him look at my
opponents down at time could I win this
one could I win this one
let's do anything man clock burner 40
where we act whoa how do I mean how am I
still up there I had that quick winner
though that 15 second er it's not gonna
be a squeaky-clean tournament though and
I'm gonna be persistent I know my
opponent knows all about hahaha they
were they were fear and that 54 ah
these aren't any fun if I have too much
of the lead I want to be doing some
catching up I want to play catch up
alright let's go here my mouse is a
little bit better to me I'm able to kind
of flip my pieces around oh yeah just
like that
I'm able to flick my pieces around and
mistakenly miss castle miss fire right
there that's what you call misfire so
what do you do when you miss fire
you have to castle artificially I've got
a backup
you got a swing over here and hope that
the h-file opens up as I can open up
we're gonna see about it problems on e6
one day maybe how does it defend rook
here Bad News Bears rook f7 that's not
working is it oh they're going into a
giant pink I was just ready to
castlelong
you can't do that you fool you already
moved your King learn the rules g4 break
at this structure here we go I got the
rope hang on the rook is pin don't take
pin pieces never usually you shouldn't
you know I meant I'm on the Rope I'm on
the pine pine takes it's a matin - no
it's a makin the knight takes it's a
meeting - for all that I got the rook
looking for mate necks making one threat
Queen h6
we need six no it's not that's not mate
the bishop was shut out of the game
let's try it again making one threat I
had it earlier I had it earlier take
pieces ah why is that king running away
give me that night give me checks give
me checks where are the checks where are
the mates why it just can't be easier
it should oh man how many mates did I
miss would you tell me Forks hit him
with a fork where's the mate Wow how
many mates how many mates would you tell
me how many did I miss back to
tournament seventy oh man okay
man I lost that game but it doesn't feel
like I uh well it did not does it feels
like I lost the game but shouldn't I be
back further
this guy's not moving I'm gonna get this
guy is he gonna move he's gonna lose in
15 seconds if he doesn't move okay here
we go
have a ball game we have a ball game
my mouse is in training he's in training
maybe I should pick that up and they
here
maybe five let's take him before it's
too late
he could be used for a pivot square okay
do this stop the night stuff kick the
bishop around also this can't help it
I can't help it but keep going for the
silly tricks in these one members silly
tricks
mmm here we go you know you want to do
it you know what age to needs to wear
are you okay
let's peel this open light Square
weaknesses is something I talked about
in that video I made it is something I
talked about be aware of it light square
weaknesses pressure against this it's
very scary
uh-oh King walks himself into a pin I
don't have to react to pawn takes Knight
I just push forward pins everywhere
Bishop's bearing down
fireworks happening on the chessboard
this time earlier it was in the
background happening pawn push no King
runs to the corner they're down on time
they don't have any time just take here
mate one threat that's me whoa back to
turn with 88 54 40s 15 minutes and
change Blaster dark alright let's try
this again and maybe successfully castle
unless that move is played that's a free
pawn oh oh oh
get ready to castle and how do they
castle is the bigger question how do
they castle uh-oh big bad Queen on the
scene rook is hit problems big problems
the rook is hit this is a mate next no
that's mate now
and 54 this guy again right
again are we gonna have a replay let's
see the improvement is there gonna be an
improvement let's take this guy I made
that adjustment tricky stuff I was
clearly being tricky right there clearly
being tricky with that mouth
okay I'm got this I'm stopping that
where's the night go there he goes
let's go I want to push this pot again
let's go here I want to stop the night
all right we're gonna clean trade or
something me I should just take in that
night here 33 seconds okay so this is
much different
Oh avoid the night exchange you move oh
how many seconds are wasted like that
get out of there night Louise trapped
it's a cook tonight a cook tonight g4
where's g4 no I just probably want to
develop there's time advantage less than
20 for white on the roof my queen cannot
be dislodged so easily they resigned
back to tournament land the granola bar
is here the granola bar is here and is
fast and furious
and I'm hungry now I'm hungry
this is some psychological trick right
here I got to do it I don't have to but
I want to I think it's right
f7 this pawn flinches f7 is weak I have
seven I'm coming after f7 I might want
to jump in here one day grab this pine
let's try it oh my oh man my
LightSquared bishop stead ha thank yous
dead man check a ruski I get the h-hey
file yeah that's that's wonderful
compensation yeah yeah you got the a
file all right you also dropped a piece
29 watch out watch out whoa I better
watch out disappear uh-oh scary time
scary time scary time ye 7b very scared
diagonals opened up I'm gonna take that
one actually it's okay to take that one
I can still play the e7 maybe Oh
let's open stuff up here maybe maybe
maybe they're chewing up time why did I
do that do I really want to open up that
dagger no more yeah let's open up a
diagonal where there's a giant battery
right here yeah that's a genius move
right there well done oh they don't have
time take this piece look at a family
fork with insurance insurance right
there am i doing just move oh I got the
Queen tricky stuff tricky I drop my
queen oh I didn't why did I do that time
situation where are you maids where are
you back to terment they're down in time
148 nobody's catching me I want it
closer
ah
okay let's see maybe I have to set
different goals let's see how many h2
attacks I could get there this isn't
even this isn't even close to being a
fishing pole but I'm gonna still somehow
try and make it happen somehow can it
still happen it might still happen
they're feeding it they're fearing it
they're fearing it uh-oh trouble rook h3
oh man is it gonna happen again
you might uh-oh Oh big trouble main
threat the King can't run away so
quickly now you're gonna run here this
is main take my rook its main back to
tournament instead of H 2 it was h1 Oh
the fisherman right there strikes again
ok let's go for some gambit c3 got some
lines here the anti are the declined
version of something ok my bishops on a
good diagonal I have control of f6 what
does that mean what does that mean it
means that there's problems maybe for
black wow they gave up their LightScribe
bishop let's get more pieces out ok and
that's serious serious damage to the
structure clean here to put pressure on
it in my knight on f3 i think is good my
knight actually wants to be right here
so a knight has to do this and it's not
doing that I'm in a pin but I think I
can get out of that I can run away let's
run away I'm okay with this I'm off upon
I have to clean now I don't have to
worry about structural damage mine I
could jump back in there but what's the
clock count here my knight needs to be
dealt with I think there we go jump up
look here
ah she done that oh hang on that's me
that's me
I was almost just gonna recapture back
to tournament 8 and change Oh
I think this is a run away oh man I'm
getting showered with points right now a
quick resigner oh man this if you're
just tuning in for the first time this
does not always happen so don't get the
wrong idea
don't get the wrong idea don't you dare
it does not always happen like this
that's for sure
rook be one with Knight b5 to follow
queenside castle maybe inside Castle now
okay what's not bishop f3 I want to be
cautious of the night getting into that
e4 square I should probably do a pawn
push let's do this first and then this
let me support it I don't want to drop
that pawn f6 is gonna be a disaster
f6 dark square weaknesses very tempted
to just not even capture that Bishop I'm
going to though it's gonna be Queen
trade there should be a queen trade it's
a very good move otherwise queen getting
to g5 is a problem jump my knight in
here hopefully it's a problem Bishop
here pin is probably good just drop
something didn't I didn't even know you
dropped something you just dropped
something you can't even define it can
you you can't even define what it is
you've been dropping there okay pawn
push why did I not pawn push right there
let's just do I have to break this
structure a little bit can I get this
diagonal bishop here rook let's take
that rook activity rook activity King
over and then what I do I look stupid no
no no just run away just run away that
Knights ready to kill me he's ready to
kill me at any moment he's ready to kill
me I got a baby
10 seconds why am i trying to win this
objectively
haha seed they have a good idea just
shuffle the king he's shuffling every
day every day is he Forks watch out for
the forks avoid the forks primo primo of
time pre move land primo primo like a
pre move can jump in here they'll never
suspect that grab here give a check
watch out for pigs pigs everywhere
pigs where the mates that's not even
mate but it's a time burner they're down
in time don't check the server yes back
to tournament 218 oh man
ah six minutes and change oh this guy I
gotta get him he's beating me oh I think
seven out of eight times something that
feels like that he is so fast I gotta
get this guy I gotta get him gotta get
him he's really quick I need a fishing
pole this guy once and forever once and
for all come on he's not gonna fall for
that okay get some material here give me
that
let's get on the light squares light
squares light squares
get out of there night get out of there
night give me this let's give a check
let's Castle before it's too late
oh I'm gonna get kicked around keep this
close my bishop is gonna fall I'm gonna
give him a it's back up you see oh I
just drama queen you see this is what
I'm talking about this guy does this
every time it's my own fault though it's
my own fault it's my own fault okay my
bishop stupid bishop right here is gonna
kill me bishop pray who's gonna kill me
no it's not I have a main threat I got
um she - I'll take that one a little
spark of excitement right there
ah the leaderboard the leaderboard is
nothing exciting though I'm gonna take
that one now I need to get that guy back
he beats me so many times you know how
that is if somebody beats you time and
time again you got to get him back you
have to get him back that's something
that was a disaster
shags they're trying to fishing pull me
right
oh I could take here it's a pin this is
a problem this is probably correct and
then just tricky discoveries pac-man
mode pac-man mode we'll hang on how long
was that there for what's that Queen
there for oh man what a disaster I think
my queen was hanging for a while Oh was
she
or was she that me me too
just move you know you want to move back
to tournament 258 it's free and change
man ah free and change here three and
change I'm not having as many Mouse lips
I am actually a bit pleased with that I
can move quicker I could move quicker is
this helping by me moving quicker can
actually get pieces to squares that I
want to go to okay I have this covered
it's very important detail but what
about this that would have been a
disaster that's what you would call a
disaster right there let's avoid
disasters please okay my Knights gonna
get kicked around or is he that's a pawn
it's a pond I'm on deadly windmills
watch out for the windmills tricky stuff
can happen on sea to be scared
Oh bad news bad news happening just
support my bishop he wants to stay right
there and then just do anything at this
point
develop back determine resigned time to
and change
man ah okay let's do it let's do it
no no no whoa go for a quick kill
against f2 what is the story with this
Queen
don't bring Queens out early right
that's what happens she gets killed she
gets killed mates soon can I calculate a
mate for once here okay take that night
take that night so I get the e-file the
e-file is where I want to be it's right
here I just want you to take stuff you
files opened up where's the mate mate
until unavoidable the King can't run
here I have that covered no the king can
run here mate coming up very soon one
minute and change remaining back to term
in 298 187 I have a lot of games in is
this really why is this happening like
this is this my mouse that's because my
mouse is faster cuz I don't feel like
I'm playing any better I'm playing not
so great and not so great that loss
really does bother me it sounds like it
doesn't bother me I'm you're
misinterpreting it like losing any game
I want to win them all I want to try and
win them all and that is not how you
would try and when I'm out it's a free
pun that is a free pawn but but what
this nights gonna land here and be
dangerous peace I really don't want a
castle this night I think jumping in
here is gonna kill me I have to come
back yes I do the night is gonna plant
up on here that could probably be good
but now it's not let's defend that night
need to castle castle
where's the forks
let's open this up he's got to go give
it a check bishops just gonna block
isn't it he up pawn push okay this is a
discovered check where's the mate ah 20
seconds this pawns fast
it's a Queen's free Queen no time first
place man I don't like those kind of
game and these tight kind of tournaments
I really don't have to believe me I like
them tight I want to be catching people
ah
all right good games